someone sold this horrifying Grimace
costume on eBay for 2500 bucks I think
what makes this costume look so creepy
is just how disjointed the arms look
from the rest of the body like it
doesn't look like his natural arms it
just looks like these these kind of
outgrowths apparently according to this
article this is a Circa 1970s mascot
suit I don't know if it's really
legitimate it doesn't look like a real
Grimace costume I think the standards of
quality in the 70s was probably a little
bit lower so you might have one
McDonald's restaurant that has like a
better Grimace costume than another it
would be very difficult to figure out
like what the actual authenticity of it
is but someone did buy this apparently
because it's no longer listing unless it
was just taken down I think I did see on
social media somewhere that it had sold
this is very weird